et madame on a mis du temps parce que le
produit certes et bien léché ses
nouvelles productions
sauf qu'on vient de se rendre compte
enfin que s'il ya bien une chose dont on
n'a rien à [ __ ] c'est bien la voix
pour un artiste maintenant des gens qui
tuent fait faire quinze amis sont
décrochés
[Applaudissements]
à vrai dire ce qu'est ce que j'en
connaisse rigolo de voir que ça n'a
strictement aucune à la raison après
c'est ce que tu as les myosotis coup
droit que j'aurais tellement c'est pour
la photo mais tu vas l'angoissé ton
choix mais je vais bien m'excuser mais
surtout qui m'angoisse pas c'était
magique ça fait plaisir d'écouter la fin
tu veux faire dix émissions de télé
crochet dans les chaînes françaises
aujourd'hui tu tournes toikeusse dans
twilight rencontrera non
m
[Applaudissements]
si l'on raconte bissau que des gens qui
chantent bien y en a énormément france
c'est pas ça qui fait un monologue
attendait la personnalité d'amateurs et
le fait d'échanger voulais juste te dire
en fait toute cette histoire c est pour
dire ça non c'est pour dire que le dès
le début les missions étaient foireuse
les gens c'est la regarder en face faut
pas les choisir de dos ça débile profond
et maintenant qui s'essouffle pas ce que
c'était
[Rires]